prime minister mitsutakis dieter yacos
ladies and gentlemen i'm very honored to
speak today
at this very special occasion for greece
and for europe
this year we are celebrating two
landmark events
at once two anniversaries
which are central to the spirit and
identity of modern greece
two hundred years ago the revolution of
independence started a revolution
which led to the birth of the modern
greek
state and 40 years ago
greece the ancient cradle of democracy
fulfilled its historic destiny and took
its
place at the heart of our modern
democratic european family so i want to
congratulate the greek people twice
today on your independence
and on your proud membership of our
union
joining the european union helped greece
young democracy to bloom
eu membership strengthened greek
institutions
and maybe most important
europe offered new horizons for greek
citizens
vast eu investment and high quality
infrastructure has transformed their
daily life
and greek businesses got access to our
single market
a unique place of opportunities
but it is not only greece that benefits
from being a member of the european
union
the same is true vice versa
our union also has gained enormous
benefits
from having greece at its core not least
in recent months
the country's vaccination campaign is
one of the most
efficient in europe it is a shining
example
of what we can achieve when we work
together
the european commission procured the
most promising vaccines for all european
citizens
and the greek authorities organized a
rollout
which is the envy of many other
countries
and when it comes to the eu certificate
greece and the european union worked
hand-in-hand
prime minister mitsutakis was among the
first
to push this idea to facilitate
travel among others for vaccinated
citizens
and i'm proud to say that the eu
certificate
will be up and running already in june
the good thing about such a close
friendship is
that you can learn from each other
just think of next generation eu our
recovery program to counter
the economic consequences of the
pandemic
with this plan the european union has
started to do
something it has never done before on
such a scale
with a strong backing of 27 member
states
the european commission is raising money
on the capital market
and together we will invest billions
in a badly needed joint recovery
we jointly invest to counter the crisis
and make our union
more digital and greener
32 billion euro of next generation eu
are earmarked for the greek recovery
and the commission works hand in hand
with the greek authorities
to make the best use of this unique
opportunity
we want to give the greek economy a
boost
we want to invest in people in jobs
in prosperity and we want to achieve a
better quality of life
for every citizen ladies and gentlemen
constantinos caramanlis the great
statesman
who masterminded greece's accession to
the european union once said
the future of europe lies in its
integration
and the future of greece lies in a
united europe
these words are as true today
as they were 40 years ago so let's use
these wise words as an inspiration for
the next
40 years sarantha honya
pio dinati mazi
you